today's panel is going to look at the
impact of international CSR standards
have they been able to influence company
behavior country behavior legislation
etc and we have a very rich panel and
varied different background so I think
it's going to be a good discussion my
immediate right left
we have chip pits it was familiar to
people at Stanford he teaches law here
and he is the former chief legal officer
from Nokia and he was involved in
drafting their code of conduct which
included human rights as early as 1997
and he'll speak more from that he's
going to be the last speaker and he's
going to look at it from the macro view
and he was also involved in the drafting
of the UN norms for multinational
companies and then we have Monica who
was a senior manager from GAAP and
incidentally we were on the same panel
last year that an anthem pack which was
you know we just realized that Monica is
representing GAAP which of course as you
know managers four of the some of the
best recognized most recognized brand
names so compliance with standards the
reputational risk is an important issue
for companies like GAAP and she's going
to talk about from the perspective of
her sector the garment sector and then
we have Ellison who is representing
varita and a client of or gap is a
client of Vera Terra and and so whatever
Monica says has been verified by in fact
if you have questions about the then you
can direct them to Allison because she's
signed off on them but Allison is
representing an organization that has
been able to that is able to work with
different stakeholders not just a
corporate sector but they're also
working with labor unions governments
organizations like mine and they are the
I remind you the leading auditing
company but they don't just audit they
also provide capacity building and
workshop and remedial solutions to their
clients so we're going to start with
Monica and then Allison and that chip is
going to put it in a larger perspective
and then we'll
it's a song can you guys hear me okay oh
it is okay well it's certainly a
pleasure to be here and I look forward
to quite an interesting discussion this
afternoon hopefully I've got some good
questions I'd like to focus a little bit
just on gaps experience in the last 10
years with CSR standards in particular
labor standards for the factories that
make our clothing I think it's fair to
say that our experience is very much
tied to that of the apparel industry as
a whole
sweatshops have long been associated
with apparel and footwear arguably more
so than they have been with other
industries although they certainly exist
in a lot of places as the apparel
industry globalized in the 1980s and
1990s sweatshops in developing countries
in particular those associated with US
and European retailers became a topic of
particular public concern in 1991
levi-strauss was the first company to
develop a code of conduct to regulate
labor standards in its third-party
suppliers a year later GAAP followed
suit and developed its own internal
sourcing guidelines which outlined
general labor standards for our
suppliers what neither we nor just about
anybody else at the time realized was
that simply outlining a set of standards
isn't enough to bring about sustainable
change this is particularly true when
you consider the types of supply chains
that are common in this industry they're
mostly comprised of third-party
suppliers that we don't own or operate
we just contract with them and this
became abundantly clear to us in 1995
three years after we had developed our
sourcing guidelines we began to receive
alarming reports of labor rights abuses
at the Mandarin International Factory in
El Salvador when we sent down our
employees to investigate they returned
with first-hand accounts of low pay
forced overtime and reported union
busting it's fair to say that Mandarin
was a wake-up call for us it was clear
that simply having a standard isn't
enough you need also need to enforce
that standard so although a lot of other
brands at Mandarin simply left we
decided to stay and try to be part of
the solution we partnered with three
organizations BSR the center for
reflection education and action and the
Interfaith center on corporate
responsibility to form an into
independent monitoring working group and
the group engaged timaeus which is a
Salvadorian civil society organization
focused on the Makela sector
and this effort marked the first
independent monitoring program in the
industry at the same time we also began
to build our internal monitoring program
in 1996 we revised our sourcing
guidelines into our first co2 vendor
conduct which is still in place today
and it's based on the ILO core
conventions we also hired our first
vendor compliance officer whose sole job
was to monitor factory conditions today
this team has expanded to over 90
individuals based in 25 countries around
the world and I'm part of this team
we've learned a lot in the last ten
years since Mandarin first and foremost
we've seen that progress is possible
especially when a wide variety of
stakeholders are engaged in the area and
probably the best example of this is
child labor it was tragically fairly
widespread in the industry some years
ago I think it's fair to say that
particularly in factories that produce
for multinational companies it's not a
common occurrence anymore we've learned
though that you can't make the kind of
long-term progress that we want to make
by working alone a single company
standard and enforcement of that
standard isn't enough for one thing
we're not the only company in the
industry although we were one of the
first to address the issue many have now
followed suit and although this is a
positive development because the more
people you have focused the better one
of the downsides is that manufacturers
are now subject to multiple audits
against multiple standards with varying
degrees of reading remediation and
follow-up I think one of the best
examples of this is fire extinguishers I
don't know if you some of you are
familiar with this but I've seen it in
some of our factories different
companies have different regulations for
what the fire extinguisher should be so
you go in and they've got several hooks
on the wall and depending on who's
visiting if they just move the fire
extinguisher around to get it to the
requisite height now this is pretty
ridiculous this doesn't do anything for
actually helping the workers and it
makes the manufacturers confused
so it's led to what we call audit
fatigue another one of the issues that
we face is that many of the issues we
find are really representative of
systemic problems that can't be
addressed just through monitoring a good
example of this would be excessive
overtime hours if a factory has poor
production processes or it's got
inefficient planning then it's the
workers that have to make up the
difference to get the product out on
time another example would be freedom of
association violations if workers aren't
aware of their rights if management is
of worker empowerment then you're gonna
run into all sorts of problems and so to
address these issues and to try to lay a
foundation for a long-term sustainable
progress in the industry we've learned
that we need to reach out to other
concerned organizations and stakeholders
these are NGOs trade unions governments
other brands and we need to build
partnerships that leverage all of our
efforts and they jointly address these
kinds of problems sometimes these
partnerships are capacity-building
programs such as those that train
workers on their rights and we've got a
couple examples at the moment in
Guatemala in China which you can read
about in our 2004 report or they teach
management techniques for supervisors
and there's a great program going on at
the moment in Cambodia around this other
times they're multi-stakeholder
initiatives like the ethical trading
initiative in the UK or social
accountability International which is
based in New York and we see these as
forums where we can really sit down with
lots of people from different
backgrounds and jointly address issues
and sort of hash out these complex
problems and we also believe that
sustainable change requires a greater
alignment of standards and expectations
manufacturers need to have a clear
understanding of what we and others
expect of them and companies like
ourselves need to be held accountable to
these standards and on that front I'd
like to mention two particular
initiatives that were involved in at the
moment one is the joint initiative on
corporate accountability and workers
rights which is comprised of six key
multi-stakeholder initiatives it has a
pilot program going on in Turkey at the
moment I'm included in this is the
ethical trading initiative and as the I
that gap is a member of the joint
initiative is working to develop a
common code of conduct and as well as a
common method to enforce that code and
it certainly we're looking to that as
potentially the initiative that will
lead to a uniform highest common
denominator standard in the industry and
we're also participating on the Global
Reporting initiatives working group to
develop a common set of reporting
indicators for the apparel and footwear
industries we've certainly learned with
our first and second public reports that
public reporting on CSR issues brings
about greater discipline and better
management within a company
unfortunately at the moment though there
is no single standard against which all
companies can be measured so we see our
work at with GRI as essential and
bringing about greater standardization
and transparency in public reporting and
this is absolutely essential to greater
corporate accountability um so I just
want to conclude by saying we certainly
hope there are efforts to develop common
standards whether it's the performance
standard through the joint initiative or
the reporting standard through GRI as
well as on many other fronts with many
other stakeholders will serve to bring
about a greater understanding of these
issues more and better solutions to some
of these problems and ultimately will
help lay the foundation for a long-term
sustainable change in the industry thank
you if you could tell us you're not only
working with the garment sector but many
different secretaries and you're not
just auditing your organization has tell
us about the variety of the things that
are happening it's encouraging to see
how big this conference has become I
know that the founder of our
organization Barrett a she started the
organization 10 years ago and before
that she was a buyer's agent in China
and she was looking at the the factories
and the conditions and the factories and
the the fires and the child labor issues
and she was disturbed by the conditions
but she what actually was more
disturbing as when she came back to the
United States and she was teaching a
class at MIT on labor issues at the
Business School and the reaction of the
Business School students in terms of the
concern and and and and thought process
into what which should actually be done
on the global supply within within the
global supply chain on these issues so
it's exciting to see sort of how many
people are interested in engaged in
these initiatives both at the at the you
know MBA and higher level education
level and also in the industry
we were we were launched in 1995
actually as a monitoring organization so
and the way we expanded as we started
with one client and then two clients in
a couple of countries and then what we
found is that when we were auditing
factories on social environmental and
labor issues that each company company
would talk to us about expanding to
where they had factories so our growth
strategy is actually I was fairly
organic
it was quick because we were expanding
to countries around the world based upon
the interests and needs of of our
clients so we're we evolved into not
just being a monitoring organization but
also we evolved in the industry into
becoming sort of doing work on training
and capacity building with corporations
as well as government institutions and
working with NGOs and multi stakeholders
on how to affect change within the
global supply chain and we're a
nonprofit organization our mission is to
ensure that people worldwide work on
their safe fair and legal conditions and
that means both working in the sort of
in the corporate with the larger
corporations and multinationals and
we're also looking at where is the
informal sector fit within the global
supply chain the issues that were
working on and as Khan mentioned that we
work across different industries so we
have worked to a great extent in the
apparel industry and but we've worked in
consumer electronics we've worked in
toys we've worked in agriculture and we
have clients like Nike and the gap and
Starbucks and McDonald's and Disney and
then we're also working with a different
number of different institutions like
Calvert and the Calvert group which I
think is represented at the conference
we've launched an initiative on women's
issues the Calvert group came up with a
initiative on advancing women in the
workplace looking at a comprehensive
code of conduct to to help sort of raise
the bar in terms of the way companies
working throughout the supply chain on
women's issues working with them on a
bunch of different initiatives we're
also working with the State Department
looking at capacity building in China
and how to look at the issues of law
enforcement and protection and
enforcement of codes in the factories
and we're also sort of meeting and
engaging with a lot of different groups
of multiple stakeholders on specific
issues like over time in the factories
and we're also looking at issues of
capacity building within different
countries and how
have a more country focused effort and
then also on improving standards not
just on some of the standards that we
passed out to you but looking at so at
standards of certification of the actual
auditors looking at the at the
management system standards and and what
needs to be improved on this and the
sort of systemic level and the
management levels within organisations
so I was trying to think about the the
sort of impact of standards and what
we've been seeing we work with about 250
institutions a year and across the board
I would definitely say that we're seeing
that the standards have are kind of a
catalyst for change and we really
believe that they're creating the
dialogue for which a lot of the
companies and organizations are coming
to us and and asking you know what they
can do in the world of sort of social
responsibility in the world of labor
rights how can they make improvements to
their supply chain there's a lot of
innovation going on as a result of these
variety of standards Veritate we don't
audit against one specific standard
we've actually created sort of a
strategy of best practices and we both
audit against those best practices which
include standards like the ILO standards
in Fla and certain corporate codes of
conduct from companies that we think are
really innovative and then we do work
with what companies like GAAP and we
experience and learn new things about
what might help to make improvements at
the factory levels or other areas of the
supply chain will incorporate those into
our art services and the programs that
we offer for the companies and in other
institutions we have definitely found
that the standards are helping to
empower or actually create a dialogue
around what's the impact of all this
work that's happening around the world
on social responsibility and definitely
believe that there's a lot more progress
and there's there's been progress but
there's a there's a way to go in in
terms of identifying what's the economic
social environmental impact of a lot of
what's happening and there's a lot of
focus on inputs in terms of how much how
how much in resources is put towards
work on the supply chain but the
question is you know what's the overall
impact on
the social standard and various
communities around the world and we're
just starting to get a lot of requests
from corporations asking us how can we
measure this can you show us can you
demonstrate you know does this mean
increase productivity in our workplaces
does this mean increase efficiencies
does it what does it mean in the
community in terms of environmental
impact and then in in terms of sort of
progress there's been a lot more sort of
consolidation and dialogue across
industries and across different
companies on how to create a more common
code of conduct and one example is and
we're engaging and sort of growing our
efforts in the electronic industry so
this morning and they you know they
talked about the HP sort of leadership
in establishing the electronic industry
code of conduct and we're doing a lot of
work to engage with the electronic
industry like companies like HP and IBM
and also the larger factories in places
like India and China to look at what's
actually been created as a common code
amongst all the companies and factories
and they sort of based this upon lessons
in the apparel industry where it would
maybe make it easier for the for their
suppliers to have one common code so the
codes been launched but the question is
in terms of standards now that now
they're looking to what kind of
standards are we gonna need in terms of
people that are going to enforce this
standard people that are gonna actually
how are they going to be trained what's
the certification process that someone
needs to go through to be to be
compliant both at the factory levels and
at the the auditor levels so these are
just some examples of how the the we've
seen sort of standards having an impact
in the work that we're doing and I would
say that probably the greatest shifts
that we've seen especially working with
companies like GAAP and some of the more
progressive sort of leaders in the
apparel industry and electronic industry
is a shift from policing to actually
it's kind of a paradigm shift to
actually creating sort of sustainable
change and not just looking at auditing
a factory and what the problems are but
really trying to figure out what are the
best programs on a sort of global level
that companies and other stakeholders
can engage upon to address and
all the solutions and the problems that
they're identifying and so that's been a
major shift and that's taken about ten
years for us to actually see this
happened at the ground level and we work
in about over sixty countries and with a
lot of different organizations and it's
really exciting to actually see the the
progress that is happening around the
the the interest and engagement to not
only look at the standards in terms of
guidance but also is resolving and
creating sustainable solutions thank you
thank you I think when we turn to your
hearing is that there is some movement
towards the convergence of standards and
we just handed out this and now we have
we have codes regulations principles we
see the industry trying to maybe
sometimes move ahead of the government
before they're regulated they want to
come up with their voluntary then we
step in not the World Bank but the OECD
steps in you know United Nations has its
own and so how does it all fit where are
we going well it's really interesting
and thank you for for moderating and
like to thank the organizers for
inviting me here Zak actually called me
up and said you're a lawyer and a
businessman but do you believe in free
speech I said well sure you know I've
been involved he writes books would you
like to give one so here I am
it is a pleasure to be here and this is
a really exciting time there are all of
these different standards and there has
been of course a long-standing
interaction between the private sector
and the public sector but I would say
we're at a very momentous change in
international law and the very
international regime in fact it used to
be called international law now it's
starting to be recognized that that that
old paradigm of international law may be
changing that legal standards as well as
ethical standards are applying to
business and my basic theme and I'm not
going to go on very long because I'd
like to get to your questions is that
these various standards are shaping a
form of law and it's the partnership's
often between NGOs and private companies
but it's it's sometimes resulting in
legal I though
as with the unocal case recently which
was a huge multi-million dollar
settlement over yuna calls alleged
complicity with the Burmese government
in pipelines but you also have
ExxonMobil being sued for its activities
in Indonesia and I check you have you
know Nikes issues you have the historic
issues of the gap a lot of the companies
have been able to use codes of conduct
to avoid litigation by internalizing
these norms and the norms are spreading
both within the private companies to the
industries that you have heard and now
for the global scene and there's a whole
spectrum of these codes they're about at
least 500 private company codes I
reviewed personally about 250 of them
five years ago when we're starting to
draft the norms looking for common
principles and and you know the highest
common denominator approach or lowest
common denominator approach the common
principles but in addition to that we've
seen the OEC guidelines on conduct which
is a multi-stakeholder approach
involving not just private companies but
also the unions and business and
governments so they have some legal
normative force you have the UN Compact
although it's strictly voluntary it's
now 10 principles on human rights labor
rights the environment and corruption
form a sort of law as people are using
these expectations to shape behavior and
as I say you know the codes if you
comply with them can be a defense to
conduct they're actually considered by
courts as a defense but if you don't
comply with with your own you know
stated norms and your rhetoric you could
be in big trouble what are the drivers
for this this remarkable development
where international law you know the
decline of state sovereignty the rise of
international organizations and their
impact the rise of private companies
influence on these common standards what
are the drivers well obviously
globalization is the big one but what
does that mean some people say that this
is nothing new that we saw really the
height of capital integration and so
forth during the the second wave of
globalization is the way some clear
people put it at the time of the first
world war where there was that expansion
until you know the war basically saw it
or trench men the first wave of course
would be the exploration period but
there wasn't a lot of integration then
but what we're seeing now is an
unprecedented
- really and interdependence we've got
trillions of dollars in capital flowing
around the world every day you've got 24
our capital markets you've got trade
going on at an unprecedented level and
you've got 24-hour media scrutiny
you know 24-hour cable news networks
you've now got Chavez talking about a
new South American Network to compete
with with CNN and so forth you also have
the explosive growth of NGOs that are
questioning these these companies and so
scrutiny is coming from all sorts of
market actors lending institutions the
lenders are concerned about risk the
institutional investors all of these
market drivers plus the internal drivers
the employees of the companies the
executives want to do the right thing
and they want to from a risk management
perspective avoid the liabilities
they're emerging so there all sorts of
drivers and we can talk more about them
in the question and answer period if
you'd like but the result is this this
new constellation of norms where there
is growing common expectations no forced
labour no child labor you know do no
harm and then do what good you can so
negative and affirmative obligations and
that's what's represented in the UN
norms for international business which
have evolved just in the last six years
or so they started with a little germ of
an idea a colleague of mine professor
David Westbrook from the University of
Minnesota was appointed the u.s. expert
to the sub Commission on Human Rights
which was the expert body that advises
the commission of human rights these are
independent experts of judges and
academics of 26 of them that advise the
Intergovernmental Commission on Human
Rights the preeminent organization
within the UN that deals with human
rights issues works with the High
Commissioner for Human Rights and he was
looking for something to do that would
respond to cutting-edge trends and so we
were talking about it and this
intersection between business and human
rights was very much on my mind I had
just both put together Nokia's code of
conduct on on human rights and Nokia
being a Finnish company was uniquely
able I think they really had wonderful
values the Finnish people I don't know
if you know them were just fantastic
people very open and
honest there at that extreme of
Transparency International's index and
they also try to do the right thing the
very moral people so it was easy to you
know in fact I was asked to do global
corporate citizenship for them and I
suggest well let's have a code of
conduct you know it's like Mickey Rooney
and let's have a show let's put a code
of conduct together and so we joined the
at that time very few companies that
explicitly and strongly committed to the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
which is at the middle of last century
the key document that says that you know
for the first time in human history you
respect even your enemies rights and it
explicitly says that private organs of
society as well as states and
individuals have human rights
responsibilities it says that in the
preamble of course that's hortatory
language and although some of it is
viewed widely now as having become
customary international law at that time
that was the gist of declaration but
then the treaties came into place the
International Covenant on Civil and
Political Rights and the International
Covenant on economic social cultural
rights and these were stymied for a
while because of the Cold War but what
ended up happening is that after the
Cold War especially space opened up to
consider them an integrated fashion and
so the UN Norm's say that within their
sphere of activity and influence not to
stand in the shoes of government but
within their sphere of activity
influence companies do have human rights
obligations and that obligation is
simple number one to do no harm not to
be a direct violator not to be complicit
in violations and simultaneously to do
what good you can now the latter is of
course harder because you know it's the
job of governments especially to provide
for economic social and cultural rights
because they're explicitly condition of
the treaty as depending on the resources
within society and so it's not the
company's job to step in the shoes of
government and for example provide
health care but if there's no government
in a place like you know in an african
nation where there is literally no
government effective government what
does a company do if it's they're
drilling for oil well what's happening
in practice what's happened for a long
time is those companies are the de facto
government
and if they're acting as the government
they have some obligations you know if
they're going to provide the services
they must do it in a way that doesn't
violate rights and that helps rights and
we're seeing coca-cola provide for
antiretroviral drugs for its workers in
South Africa for example so the UN norms
are an exciting effort that cover the
international civil political and
economic social cultural rights they
also have processed values that say that
before you take actions that affect an
indigenous community for example you
consult them and we did this at Nokia we
didn't have the norms at that time but
when we built a factory in the
rainforest in Brazil we said what's the
right thing to do well let's talk to the
local people that are affected before we
built the factory had a dialogue with
them a stakeholder dialogue and that was
what the norms suggest you do similarly
if you're providing security for
services for your plant protect your
plant either by private security forces
or hiring either government on duty or
off duty military or police forces to
protect your plant you do your due
diligence as you should from any risk
management perspective you make sure
you're not hiring people that were
former human rights violators like death
squads in guatemala el salvador or
people that have involved in violations
of you know as has happened with shell
in nigeria in 1995 when they were
accused and roundly accused by world
public opinion of being complicit in the
death of ken sarah we will now these
issues are not going away unfortunately
we are still seeing violations despite
the the increased normative development
that's going on just in the last couple
of weeks
Amnesty International is a report
updating its prior reports saying that
there's still problems with Chevron and
shell and Nigeria the security forces
are still killing people with impunity
and as you're probably aware if you
follow the news there have been several
deaths of people protesters if show and
Chevron factories in the last year so
you know there are still these these
major problems at the larger level
aside from individual company incidents
we have a serious problem with the macro
perspective the real macro perspective
and that's evidenced by persistent
poverty and inequality
the world the UN Human Development
Report once again this year says that
poverty and inequality are increasing
now why is that of concern to all of us
it's of concern because if that happens
eventually businesses won't have any
consumers to sell - there's a shrinking
middle class there's no market and of
course there's also major backlash
possible both in terms of companies
having protesters at their plants but
also in terms of security I mean you
actually have things like the free trade
agreement of the Americas being you know
butch was shoot out of Latin America
basically last week when he was visiting
Argentina and Brazil so without a more
ethical globalization there's not going
to be you know a sustainable effective
form of capitalism so there really is a
strong business case even at the macro
level I would argue for making sure that
business is not part of the problem but
part of the solution and I'll stop there
we can talk a little bit more about some
of the the companies like the gap and HP
and Barclays Bank that are actually Road
testing the norms these these common
level playing field platform norms that
try to pull the best of the different
regional and all of these other
confusing disparate standards some of
which are very good I don't mean to
disparage them but it is impossible for
companies to comply with you know a
hundred different codes and and the
variant expectations so there really
needs to be a rationalization what are
the key norms that we need to comply
with and then more learning and sharing
of best practices as to how we do it but
that our standards are always changing
they're moving targets for companies how
do you keep up with that and you could
comment on the upcoming ISO standards or
CSR eyes is that a positive thing
negative thing and compared to maybe the
UN Global Compact and of course they're
very different in nature well I'll start
by saying that I know that when we
conduct our audits and program
assessments and working with companies
especially if we find many times we will
find that the company isn't compliant
not necessarily because of their own
standards
of the other standards that we're using
to to evaluate that company's
performance with the suppliers
performance and so what we tend to do is
we turn that back around and establish a
dialogue with the company with the
suppliers as to what do you think you
should do given that you may be
compliant on a lot of your own internal
standards but here's where we've pointed
out that you can actually improve your
performance and so we're doing a lot
more training and consulting and sort of
advising around if you are if you don't
have a standard on prison labor for
instance but that has been established
as something that a lot of companies are
engaging and discussing about whether
they should be supplying from the the
prisons then we'll have a dialogue with
the company to say how important do you
think this is and in terms of
incorporating incorporating that into
your into your vendor compliance guides
into your code of conduct and how do you
reflect that the other thing I'll just
say is that it's it's even difficult for
an organization like ours to keep up
with the the growing number of standards
and initiatives and what we basically
just try to do is to identify what's
sort of common ground and common
understanding with a lot of our
different clients in terms of what they
think is most important and then we also
try to look at government institutions
and other sort of objective independent
bodies to identify how the standards are
continuously updated yeah I mean the
approach that we've generally taken and
the reason we haven't revised our code
of conduct in 10 years is that you can't
have a moving target for your
manufacturers you can't keep changing
every year what they have to comply with
but where you've seen us make changes is
at the policy level so when we go in
when we on it what does our remediation
plan look like you've seen us refer to
the ETI base code 2s 8000 what's
interesting is that our suppliers
particularly as we've developed a
balanced scorecard as social
responsibility becomes part of decision
making our suppliers are suddenly
interested in going above and beyond the
basis in our code event or conduct
didn't so you see the suppliers actually
saying how can I achieve as a
sort of certification of what training
programs can i implement which I think
in our view is the ideal situation we
don't want to be hammering them saying
you have to reach this level we want
them coming to us and saying okay how
can we do even more than what you're
asking so I think that's been a positive
development what we are watching I mean
we would love to adopt an industry-wide
code that everybody was subject to but
because it has an emergency ette I think
we're sitting back we're watching we're
evolving parts that we can depending on
what organizations were involved with
but at in the future of something
emerges I think you'll see a gap joining
just to add a bit I think that you know
my interest in this is some of that
previously had to also work with all
these disparate codes is is we want
something that is is fairly clear and
simple for business to understand one of
the problems with some of the codes is
that they are extremely complex a lot of
times you know it's couched in this
pseudo scientific gobbledygook language
that implies that there's a single right
answer when there's not a lot of times
what you really need is not a
rules-based approach maybe at some level
for a specific company and industry you
drill down to rules ultimately but what
you've got to have is a real
comprehensive agreement on standards not
general principles as general as the
work with Global Compact which were good
at the time you know when they were
enacted after Kofi Annan suggested that
they be put in place in 1999 at Davos
but they are very general it just says
you know companies shall respect you
Human Rights what does that mean you've
got to drill down below that that's why
I like personally the UN norms which in
turn reference a lot of the other key
standards the OECD guidelines SI 8,000
for example and then what companies can
do is have a useful checklist to kind of
take it down to the level of detail that
they need but we need a single in my
opinion international document that
brings together in a way then the norms
do imperfectly of course because they're
a product of comity and there are some
things in there that I disagree with but
the idea is that you've got it sort of a
collective action problem you really
with the race to the bottom globally it
may be in the system's interest to avoid
that increasing poverty and inequality I
mentioned but it may be in the interest
of any one company or any one country to
not comply with the highest standards
and so how do you overcome that
prisoner's dilemma or that collective
bargaining problem that the collective
action problem what you do in game
theories that says you have clear rules
and enforcement mechanism that's
basically the sort of common denominator
put so it makes a lot of sense now
there's a political problem in getting
to that because you know even though a
lot of individual companies will say
they support it a lot of times the trade
associations like the International
Chamber of Commerce the International
Organization of employers have a
knee-jerk reaction against any
regulation of any kind and yet you do
have other business organizations like
the business leaders initiative for
Human Rights which the gap is part of
along with some of the other companies I
mentioned or the Prince of Wales
International Business Leaders Forum or
some other business groups that are
announcing the value of this common
platform that sets forth as the UN norms
do in 18 principles it's very readable
you can read the thing in a half an hour
what the basic principles are and then
reference the other key standards and
then that would have been for me at
Nokia when we had that rainforest
situation I was talking about a very
useful checklist of saying well you
consult you know you make sure that you
you know you do not do this you do do
your due diligence and so forth and so
and you just go through the checklist
and it's it's a very practical clear
thing that's what we need now how are we
going to get there right now the Special
Representative for Human Rights in
business John Ruggie that cookie nun is
appointed it's considering the norms
actively they have survived and
prospered through a couple of rigorous
reviews at the Commission of Human
Rights there was a very strong effort to
kill them but these UN norms for
transnational corporations are still
alive and kicking they were welcomed at
the last Commission and in February of
this year and you know he is a now in
the in the process of determining their
status visa via the other status the
other instruments that are sort of the
key instruments out there
and I would hope that we you know we
have support from the private sector for
for this initiative because that's in my
opinion what we need to to address the
problem that you're talking about most
of the standards seem to be OECD based
are they embraced by companies outside
of the OECD zone and if there happens to
be a normative law global normative law
what will be the enforcement mechanism
for that law and simply as there are the
norms competing with one another are
there incentives what kind of incentives
exist for countries outside of the OECD
zone to comply with the standards and
maybe if I can put this even in more
general the panel question is do these
standards actually have impact on the
ground have you seen any externalities
is you know gap suppliers maybe are not
compliant but are there are there larger
larger is there larger impact also if
you could I don't know who would like to
take that you don't all have to take it
easy
I do address the OECD I think an
interesting development this year has
been the emergence of the new standard
in China and it's gonna be interesting
to see what impact that has now the
problem is it doesn't have a ton of
credibility with certain sets of
stakeholders because there's no freedom
of association clause particularly with
the trade union so it's going to be
interesting we're certainly watching
with interest our suppliers are asking
if we comply with this is this enough we
come back and say well you still need
the some aspect of parallel means within
the Chinese context I think what we're
seeing as you see more and more
integration of social responsibility
into business you're starting to see
suppliers based in developing countries
saying okay I want to implement this for
me
they're also recognizing that in many
respects this does help them run a
better business so if you're more
efficient you have less overtime your
workers are happier you actually are
more productive you are making more
money and gap actually is measuring you
as well on how you're doing that so I
think as we you have to have some sort
of tangible business interest but as
that's coming out more and more as we're
seeing more Studies on that we're
starting to see the suppliers take
ownership and by way of that also
driving it within there
country's so in Sri Lanka for example
we've got a couple of really fabulous
suppliers and I think they're trying to
take it out to a lot of their colleagues
and say okay you need to be doing this
as well this is the right way to be
doing business it's also the best way to
be doing business so it's exciting I
mean it's it's at a nation sort of an
aching phase at the moment but I think
it's growing yeah I was gonna mention
the code in China as well and we just
held a supplier conference with about
150 suppliers and China to not only
discuss what opportunities there were to
remediate problems at the factory levels
but what's what are the opportunities to
discuss the confusion and the
opportunities with all these different
standards and how can the suppliers sort
of react and address a lot of issues
that are demanded of them by multiple
brands and multiple stakeholders and it
was very interesting dialogue because we
had it was a focus on suppliers and on
the factories but the the brands and
other stakeholders were sort of engaged
in that effort and so we're seeing a lot
more of these sort of more country base
and industry based conferences and
forums to really discuss how to
interpret the different standards and
what it actually means in terms of the
the need for the the suppliers to be
more proactive they have to wait for the
the dialogue with the brands to you know
help them enforce these these codes and
in terms of the Chinese context we last
year initiated along with a number of
other brands some dialogue with the
Chinese government and that really was
sort of going to the government level
and talking about how better labor
standards actually makes China more
competitive and it was well received I
mean it's still at a beginning phase but
I think when you start to see dialogues
like that I'm looking potentially at the
regulatory level you suddenly see a lot
more interests at the country level I
think that's a very important point I
mean this is a China is an intractable
problem in terms of human rights
obviously the idea that economic
liberalisation would lead to political
liberalization just hasn't happened
because the government has so much power
it can calibrate the degree of freedom
based on you know what it wants and yet
and yet this is one of the most
attractive
News four furthering political freedom
as as you just heard Monica say the
Chinese government does understand what
you know they listen to what business
wants and if businesses explain our
consumers care about this we cannot have
forced labor in this factory we can
cannot countenance two sets of books
which we had a Nokia after I left
actually there was a film produced on
what was happening right after I left
the film is called a decent factory and
it's very disturbing one of Nokia's
departure no no no even my departure it
was it was actually well after I left
the film just came out this this year
but it was involving a subcontractor of
Nokia that was not complying with the
new minimum labor law and China the
minimum wage law and they had two sets
of books really which is quite common in
many different countries and yet that's
obviously you know it's like the fire
extinguisher problem on a more serious
scale and and yet if we explain to the
Chinese government and those suppliers
and subcontractors that this is not
possible our consumers will not buy our
products if we're not complying with
basic international norms and our
lenders won't lend us money the sources
of capital well will punish us on the
stock market you know if this comes out
our stock price will drop you know they
will understand that and work with you
and Chinese government is also starting
to understand the role of an independent
judiciary and the rule of law it's still
of course not there it's still a major
problem you basically have what Stephen
Breyer of the Supreme Court calls
telephone justice you know and that's
that what happens in a lot of cases the
powerful can make their views known and
get the results they want but it was a
major problem in business curious about
this is a problem there they're powerful
businesses voices in China both doing
business there and businesses within
China are speaking up which brings me to
your question about the OECD countries
and the enforcement and the reality is
even though there are there's a lot of
movement in developing countries as well
in this the most transnationals are from
the developed world of course and if
again they set forth that these are
their requirements in their supply chain
as the gap is done as Verity is
encouraging its clients to do you you
will start to see results and we are
starting to see results as Monica
alluded child labor is much worse of a
problem just in the last few years it's
still a problem I mean we still are
seeing it Amnesty Human Rights Watch
many reports of egregious situations but
it's less of a problem the problem of
sexual harassment is still very very
serious the problem of you know
discrimination against women is still a
major global problem that's affecting
development and that macro picture
adversely that I reference but you know
ultimately these norms are a sort of
enforcement on their own
Louis Inc and the the distinguished
international law scholar says you know
well these people that say international
law is not law because there's no
enforcement mechanism are really wrong
it is law because most people comply
with it most of the time or else would
have you know really unstable situation
and actually you know we are now
starting to see more powerful
enforcement mechanisms with teeth and I
mentioned the at Colossus the Alien Tort
Claims Act there's a couple of hundred
billion dollars in liability pending in
the US courts that model of domestic
litigation is also happening now in
Australia in the UK in another country
so that's one thing you go up from there
you have regulatory agencies the US and
in most developed countries now have
anti-discrimination laws they comply
with human rights for the most part they
have laws against you know forced labor
or sexual trafficking or what-have-you
and that's starting to spread around the
world as well so you've got regulatory
agencies you have these multilateral
treaties the trade treaties are
increasingly starting to include some
references to labor and human rights
although weekly that's starting to you
know to improve a bit and now you have
these multilateral efforts at the
international level that I think are
starting to come together
you know with you know with the
standards organizations but also this
new normative instrument in the UN so
enforcement is is still a problem
certainly but I think that you know the
market power of business is insisting
that this be part of their business
model is it's one of the best jobs we
have for actual progress in the future
arcane information technology help
collect the information that is needed
and how well is it's integrated into
these measurement systems as
redevelopment matrix in our experience
the challenge has been that IT has not
kept up with the pace of development
here so in I mean just looking at the
gap situation our IT systems are
completely antiquated for what we really
need to measure this like our ideas and
our approach to measurement has far
outpaced what our IT systems are capable
of we're actually in the middle of
trying to adopt a new system I think the
challenge that we run into is many of
the providers particularly the big
providers that will also mesh with
company systems aren't necessarily aware
of the detail level that we need so we
have to do a lot of the requirements we
have to do a lot of the work on the
front end to make sure the system is
compatible there are niche players but
they may not be able to mesh well with a
company systems generally and we need
things that can pull from our production
I mean mesh with our supply chain I mean
it has to work there as well just to
give you some names I mean I know Oracle
and Siebel are one pretty good provider
Hitachi is another one but again it's
it's a challenging field out there
because a lot of them really don't
understand the detail of what we're
getting at and it's evolving I mean
we're evolving it ourselves internally
it's changing every year the way that we
measure
I would advise those companies if they
want to get into it they really need to
have an ongoing discussion with
companies that are at the cutting edge
of this measurement so that they can
evolve their systems along with it
they're also expensive and they're
expensive to update so you need a system
that can continue to evolve with this
field you know just add that I think
it's an incredible opportunity both on
the entrepreneurial side and in looking
for opportunities down the road and
working in this field I did some work
with sa P at their headquarters and I
know what it looks like when they've got
people coming in on a global basis to
establish requirements of the next sort
of stage of development on systems like
this and I've been wondering just when
it was going to happen that some of
these you know companies are going to
roll out is something too effective CSR
you know comprehensive CSR systems not
only to collect information but also to
aggregate it in a way that we can
evaluate the impact of all these efforts
that are that are occurring and that
would help a lot of the
governmental organizations and the NGOs
who are trying to make the business case
to the companies and make the case to
other institutions that these
initiatives and these efforts are really
viable and they do really help address
issues like poverty and I what we've
been seeing is we've been seeing the
development of some of these systems and
ideas but nothing is comprehensive but I
think is like Monica seen to keep up
with the developments in the field
especially with regard to standards yeah
I don't have much to add except a the
systems I've seen or funky and bad so I
think there is an opportunity there but
it's it's it's a tough one it does
require working with the cutting-edge
companies I wanted to let your date that
we dropped your GC question about the
Global Compact in the eyes of some
companies particularly companies that
are not doing a good job of complying
with human rights there is tension
between Global Compact in these other
norms and they want to keep their eggs
in the Global Compact basket so again
the problem with that is that the Global
Compact
I think serves a serves an important
preliminary purpose of defining the
basic principles and sharing best
practices that it's strictly voluntary
and it's been subjected to some
legitimate criticism that some of its
members are actually using it and what
they call blue wash you know like the
blue helmets from the UN they're using
is kind of public relations cover from
for continued violations and there's
some prominent examples of that so you
know the Global Compact is good as far
as it goes but it's at that very general
standards level a principals level we
need to drill it down into standards and
and rules for the industries and
companies but keeping them still clear
and simple as I mentioned and that's
where again the software is going to
have to you know be very very user
friendly and you know you automate as
much as you can but there's some things
in here they're just not going to be
ultimately automated they'll still be a
lot of human interaction as there is
with a lot of good software present the
the solution to enforcement is and will
remain pluralistic it's basically the
norms contain an article 16 I think it
is not you know a heavy-handed approach
saying this is the way these will be
enforced but it contains a roadmap to
possible ways of enforcement and it
mentions possibly adding
some illustrative private-sector
communications complaints could go to un
treaty bodies for example that's one
possibility
national courts national legislators
national regulatory agencies other
perhaps you know to be developed future
monitoring capabilities by the
International Labor Organization or by a
special mandate say John Ruggie the
current Special Representative the UN
may be given a mandate to receive
complaints that's actually the way the
UN system has developed human rights
although they're weekly and and
effectively enforced there have been
some positive enforcement mechanisms in
the Human Rights deal because individual
complaint mechanisms are available under
optional protocols to some of the
treaties there's a confidential what's
called a 1503 procedure for state to
state complaints and so forth so there's
a whole panoply of enforcement
mechanisms Harold Koh the Dean of Yale
Law School former Clinton administration
official in charge of Human Rights
speaks about enforcement with an analogy
toward a candid driving on a road where
at first it starts you know you drive on
the right side because it's convenient
to do so and then you may start because
of a speeding ticket you know compliance
model and then you start to
operationalize the norms internally and
what I'm saying is that the real change
will will happen when these companies
their employees operationalize when they
communicate for the sustainability and
human rights and labor rights
environmental reports as a lot of them
are doing now what they're doing and
then consumers will get educated and
stakeholders collectively will enforce
it in this sort of pluralistic model
than talking about so it's going to take
it's not a silver bullet it's gonna take
a lot of continued effort by a lot of
players in my opinion the World Bank has
no human rights initiatives as well
picture as well a new
we did another supply chain question we
didn't want to leave the supply chain
question I did say something about how
far down do you think we can go down
supply chain in terms of holding a
company accountable there was a panel in
this room yesterday and McDonald was
asked that question and she couldn't she
wasn't allowed to answer I think she
wanted to answer we chatted afterwards
but she was saying that McDonald's is
looking at for example what the if
they're buying beef they're only looking
at the processors compliance was
processing the beef and selling it to
them but they're not looking at the
farms actually so I mean it's definitely
a good question it's one that we're
facing now what I have seen both in
reporting and in monitoring is a trend
to try to define about the boundary
somewhere because many different
stakeholders are approaching us with
many different ideas some saying we
should all go all the way down to the
cotton farms and what are the conditions
on the cotton farms now we are a big
buyer of cotton but you think about how
far removed that is from any sort of
whether direct or indirect relationship
we have with the business it's pretty
far what I'm seeing is sort of a matrix
approach that's trying to grade it based
on the amount of influence or control
that a company has different companies
have started to define that in their own
way
I think gap is gonna need to do that as
well because there are plenty of groups
that are approaching us and saying you
need to do something with cotton I don't
know if we'll get there or not but the
idea I mean it's it's hard enough to do
it in third-party owned facilities that
we contract with but there is a direct
relationship there it's hard and we
don't own them so we still have trouble
sort of convincing them but at least we
can use our business as the leverage
when you are so far removed they sort of
look at you and say well why should I do
what you say it's not like you're going
to be giving me a web Pio or anything so
it's it's it's an emerging question that
I think more and more companies are
gonna deal with this issues come up in
the electronic industry as well we just
had with the US Department of Labor we
did a conference in India to look at
what are the most sort of prominent
issues in the supply chain for
electronics come
and one of the major issues is e waste
and in particular there are a lot of
entrepreneurs out there are just
individual families women and children
who are breaking apart the the
motherboards and through the sort of
recycling effort and are exposed to a
lot of hazardous materials and so the
industry is trying to come together with
a lot of stakeholders to say who's
responsible for this and how can we
protect these these families and these
children from working in this industry
but also not get in the way of the fact
that this is an economic you know
opportunity for these individuals and to
really address the the the sort of issue
carefully carefully so it's it's in sort
of beginning stages of trying to
identify who's responsible throughout
the supply chain for an issue like that
I'll just add that I think that it
depends a lot on the industry and the
company because you know supply chains
if you think about it are very different
say for Ford or for the gap which
competes a lot of brand and quality or
for Walmart Walmart was just sued a
couple of weeks ago yeah and if supply
chain of course is very different it's
tens and tens and thousands of suppliers
and a lot of piece work done sometimes
in-house work and informal even sort of
black market suppliers to keep the price
down and yet you know gap and and
Walmart do have different types of
control over their suppliers and so the
the concept of sphere of activity and
influence and control is a very
importantly what does a company know you
know to what extent does have really
control does it have bargaining power
over that supplier and how deep into the
chain does it have it and then what
positive or negative influence kind of
exert in another trend that we're also
seeing is the consolidation of suppliers
for companies and what respond and the
question that comes up regularly is
what's the responsibility of the company
that is closing down a factory in one
particular region and moving it to an X
or closing it down and with regard to
the consolidation what responsibilities
do those does the company have for that
community and we've been doing a lot of
work with the number of companies who
called us and have said that they had
unexpected reaction from the community
in which they closed a factory even
though they thought that they really
gave us a lot of sensitivity to the
community issues and they'd established
some education programs and you know
initiatives for the community but it's a
difficult issue for the company to
address and figure out what their
responsibility is and it does require a
lot of multi stakeholder engagement with
the local government officials and with
the local NGOs to figure out what they
can do and what they have the capacity
to do I just more thing in the recent
meeting that we had for the GRI working
group it was an interesting discussion
because they're debating issue of how
far a company should be required to
report and its supply chain and on the
group you have both brands and retailers
as well as NGOs and trade unions and it
was interesting because the the
suppliers felt very strongly that the
brands responsibility only went to a
certain level and they're like actually
it's our responsibility to go further
down into that supply chain because
we're the ones buying the fabric we're
the ones buying that and we really think
that we need to drive that among our
peers as opposed to you brands
regulating it for us so it was just an
interesting discussion we'll see where
it goes as the standard is developed but
are there any studies being done on
developing matrix that look at the
inherent conflict between pushing for
more CSR standard strict CSR standards
while keeping up the productivity it's a
great question and we're still at the
beginning phases what I can tell you is
that I'm not sure I'd agree with that
it's an inherent conflict it may be in
the short-term but not in the long term
and what we've seen just as we've
undergone some supply chain redesigns on
our own is that when we when we miss our
delivery time or we miss our PPO to
vendor time we miss getting the sort of
the samples to the vendors on time we're
also ruining our own supply chain we're
adding cost to us so the way in which we
can reach our business partners is to
say you know if you if you make your
decisions appropriately and we measure
you against that not only is that going
to help the factories but it's gonna
cost us less - but it's a new way of
working especially in apparel I think
other industries are further ahead in
this area
it's just come more natural but it's a
pretty logical way of thinking we're in
the midst right now of where
part of a working group with the ETI
exploring sort of talking to our
business partners and just trying to
understand what's happening hopefully a
report will come out in a couple of
years with the results we've been doing
a lot of trainings one of about sixty
thousand workers in China recently on
life skill issues economic literacy
health issues infectious diseases also
and just came back from Bangladesh and
we're doing a big training there with
one of our clients at the factory levels
training about 15,000 women workers and
there are certainly there are a lot more
companies and organizations asking
what's the overall impact of that work
both on a productivity efficiency sort
of level that's of concern to the
suppliers at to the brands but also in
terms of just the overall sort of social
impact and what we've been trying to
identify is other organizations and
stakeholders to bring together the the
questions of what indicators should we
use to measure that impact and if you do
some trainings of workers on
reproductive health rights and the women
are more aware of their their rights in
that regard what's the actual impact on
the you know in the factory in terms of
productivity and can you see a decrease
in the amount of doctor visits that that
woman is going on on a yearly basis and
that could be you know have an effect on
increased savings and you know decrease
costs but the tracking of that
information and also having a baseline
for establishing what you're going to be
evaluating is really is pretty tricky
and it's a challenge for us to negotiate
at the supplier level to actually have
the time to set up those systems and the
ability to attract that information
especially during the high seasons so
it's it's definitely an opportunity out
there I don't think that there are we'd
like to be part of more you know
initiatives and establishing better
indicators both but I agree with Monica
that that you know we we have seen and
we believe that it's not as much of a
conflict as there's real benefits to
both in looking at how the impact on the
a social environmental level can help
increase the the value proposition that
the company and the suppliers have
and I'm I'm very glad to hear that they
think there's not a conflict because
that is that is the right answer but the
reality of course you know it's the
right answer because if you think about
it if a young girl is slave chained to a
sewing machine as working you know seven
days a week 14 to 18 hours a day she's
not going to be very productive after a
little while now so it depends a little
bit on the context the substitutability
of the labor the level of skill involved
agricultural laborers are often viewed
as fungible but to the extent you you
train the skilled workers your employees
are a very important asset that you've
invested in so even from a cold calculus
you know you need to treat them in a way
that comports with basic human dignity
so that they will be productive and
enthusiastic and that's why these norms
part of the business case is that it
does help employee retention and in
recruitment and so forth but sometimes
there can be a conflict obviously if
you've got one unit saying you know push
push push
rush rush get to get the job done at a
lower price Walmart say and you've got a
CSR person you know who is saying we
cannot do that those units can be in
conflict which one is going to win the
day it depends on the top leadership in
their view of shareholder versus
stakeholder value their commitment the
internalization of these norms Oxfam has
a good report on this that they did
about a year ago and what they say like
some of the business literature on this
and some of the icould legal academic is
that you've got to have an integrated
approach part of your training must be
but these aren't just abstract
principles that they really do affect
our long-term big-picture interest in
our you know the the way our
stakeholders view us and the way our
company will be perceived as
contributing something of value in a you
know the the good to great idea that you
know is very popular right now Jim
Collins book the company that will will
be of lasting value to society and not
just producing short-term quarterly
profits I think the gap has made a lot
of progress they a lot of times the
progress comes out of companies that
went wrong and they had some problems
and now they're one of the leaders same
thing with a lot of these other
companies the business leaders
initiative for Human Rights that they're
part of they've all committed to some
kinds of standards they're Road testing
these you and norm
but there are you know there's about
8590 percent agreement on the basic
content of the norms so there you don't
have a problem but in any individual
industry in the apparel industry you
have a spectrum of bad guys and good
guys and in the in the extractive sector
you have a lot of bad guys but you've
got companies like BP that are doing
really well
companies like shell that are doing you
know better but as I mentioned still
have problems companies like Exxon but
still have a long way to go you know so
it really it varies but by having some
of the largest most profitable companies
in the world
Walmart got religion two weeks ago you
see you know you know they're suddenly
saying hey you know what this stuff
isn't after it we've been sued it's not
so bad after all
and we recognize that we can now comply
and it's not even to cost us a lot of
money so all of a sudden you know it's
possible for there to be normative
change but the leaders make an impact I
just wanted to add that in terms of I
feel like especially in our industry
there's been an embracement of standards
but it's the level and port of
enforcement that differs and you've got
leaders who are really coming in and
saying this is what we mean and we're
not gonna be satisfied until you do X
whereas you've got others saying okay
well we'll give you some room some
wiggle room I was just in China last
week and our field director came and
said you got a look at this and it's a
consulting company that has sprung up on
mainland China that is instructing
companies how to create double or triple
or quadruple sets of books so that they
can comply with all of the different
retailers requirements I mean that's
literally their industry because they
know I mean we take a very firm stance
we find double books that's it we're
gone
and we say we don't care what we don't
care how many sets of books you have as
long as you show us the true ones and so
working with our suppliers they know
it's a tough line eventually they're
going to show us the books are they're
gonna lose our business but there's
plenty of other companies who may or may
not really want to know and may not dig
in and there's a whole industry sprung
up to to add those layers if that's what
if actually wants to do and if a company
is not willing to look deeper so you see
that level of enforcement and that's
what makes it challenging in the
industry to because we take a tough line
and and not everybody does question on
wage standards wage
yeah how do you set the right weight
standards in different countries
different so I guess Monica comes back
to you let me start with the laggards
question first I think it's a great
question and unfortunately at the moment
I think it's highly dependent on
consumer so when consumers are engaged
when there's a lot of media around the
company it does like gap and Nike it has
forced us to become a leader in the
industry the hope is that in seeing more
lawsuits both the ones that we were
subject to in the past the ones that
Walmart is subject to now this will
increase awareness it is also potential
to increase regulation so you're seeing
in Europe for example the the new
operating and Financial Review
requirement in the UK or the
non-financial reporting requirement in
France even the socks requirement
although it's not specifically CSR in
the u.s. it is sort of a form of
governance based on scandals as you see
more and more of that and as companies
are required to account publicly for
what they do the hope is it will slowly
level the playing field but again at the
moment it is still unfortunately largely
dependent on consumers we haven't talked
much about the crater principles but in
the sort of financial industry there is
a bunch of shareholder activism that
occurred and as a result since JPMorgan
Chase hadn't joined the the Equator
Principles they established in response
that the office for Environmental
Affairs that reports to the Chairman
directly and as a lagger they now have a
very public commitment to trying to sort
of work on these issues so I think like
Monaco is saying there are a number of
different ways that I know that we get
calls as to why laggers in the industry
want to work with us and some of them
it's because of shareholder activism
some of it's because they're getting
nervous that they're sitting and
watching this all happen and they're not
exactly sure what to do or if they
should sit tight or if they should
respond and how publicly they should
should respond and interestingly enough
I was in a meeting
recently with a with a company and and
someone said well I'm not sure how to
react to everything that's happening
with Walmart I don't know if it's gonna
make it more difficult on a global basis
for companies to actually do work in
this industry or if companies are gonna
get scared from actually taking a
leadership role in these efforts and it
was just was an interesting dialogue
that we had because they were definitely
considering what they wanted to do in
regards to all the new standards and
their efforts and in managing their
supply chain but they weren't exactly
sure how to how to react so the public
pressure and the stakeholder activism
the shareholder activism consumer
activism and and also the just general
risks and lawsuits do start the the
grassroots sort of thinking as to